bon on va rester dans les jeux de salon
la joue faire un petit anti portrait
chinois
merde bougez pas
vous connaissez le portrait chinois non
je vais pas me voici le portrait chinois
c'est un jeu qui est vieux comme on dit
si vous étiez une fleur dit surin mieux
autistes ou lentilles porter chinois
c'est autre chose a bossé linverse tab
on dit si vous étiez à défaut vous
seriez quoi comme défaut avant j'en sais
rien encore ne vous aller me reposer
après justine maladie enfin ce serait la
coqueluche fut rien si vous étiez un
accident circulation si vous étiez une
perversion la pire vite une guerre sans
dentelles un dictateur papy nash est une
arme de pacotille
un supplice chinois une cicatrice
d'amour citya nasa
landru parce qu'il aimait les femmes si
vous étiez un [ __ ] vous pas mal non